ça y est le moment est venu je peux
enfin vous en parler les amis
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du plus
gros projet de l'histoire pas de
machines youtube parce que c'est pas un
projet vidéo mais de ma carrière dans le
métier une carrière et tout comme il se
la pète tout d'abord ce n'est pas que
mon projet il ya plein de gens qui ont
bossé là dessus mais l'idée est née en
juillet 2014
quand après avoir fait plusieurs neige
sur cyprien gaming cyprien me dit c'est
sûr vous êtes webtv avec tous les gens
conquis pas pourquoi par la super allez
tu t'en occupes au revoir mais tu as le
roumain non c'est faux pardon c'est faux
il a trouvé le nom et pour ça il a
durement travaillé le stream merci
cyprien pour ta participation sur ce
projet binger grave crise qu'a duré la
cave vachement et des gens fait des
caisses mais voilà j'ai envie de le van
est ok alors le stream c'est quoi
connaissez-vous twitch connaissez-vous
le live sur internet vous connaissez
déjà peut-être zerator skyarts jiraya
domingo afin casse gotaga y en a bien
d'autres
ce sont des streamer des gens qui jouent
aux jeux vidéo en live sur internet
et quand et streamer se regroupent pour
proposer différents programmes à
différentes plages horaires ça donne une
web tv et le stream point fr qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est une web tv
ça monte très très loin mais on avait
vraiment envie de faire un projet avec
tous les gens qu'on aime qu'on a été
amené à croiser ou voir même à
travailler avec pour certains on s'est
dit [ __ ] mais ces gens ils sont trop
cool on aime trop ce qu'ils font ils
sont hyper sympa il faut vraiment qu'on
bosse ensemble plus que ça qu'on fasse
plus souvent des trucs ensemble en bonne
ambiance pas forcément sur des jeux
vidéo mais voilà on avait cette envie de
faire des trucs avec et sur youtube
bah j'ai envie de faire des vidéos où je
suis parfois avec des gens aussi souvent
quand je suis seul donc fallait faire un
truc en plus et c'est là où vous êtes
content parce que ça fait plus de
contenu pour vous vous n'êtes pas
content c'est que le lancement est raté
on s'est alors mis à contacter tous ces
gens qu'on appréciait de près ou de loin
est alors proposé le projet à leur dire
les gars venant fenway mtv tous ensemble
ça va être génial
bon on a vu plus développé que ça parce
que ça nous aurait dit non mais bon et
on a été super content parce que tous
ces gens ont accepté mais c'était il ya
deux ans le site avait énormément de
temps à être fait mais du coup parlons
du site qu'est ce que vous pouvez
retrouver sur ce site et bien comme je
vous ai dit à la web tv c'est la chaîne
principale du site c'est de midi jusqu'à
2h du mat ou les jours ça commence à
midi et ça finit dans la nuit et chaque
jour ça recommence à midi et ça a fini
dans la nuit et selon les heures il ya
différents des missions qui vous sont
proposés avec différentes personnes par
exemple de 12 heures à 14 heures ça peut
être quelqu'un qui fait du jeu vidéo de
14 heures à 16 heures ça peut être
plusieurs mecs qui vont faire des jeux
de société lien
tout du jeu vidéo pas du jeu vidéo une
toque chaude du sport regarde vraiment
de tout sur cette voie de tv parce qu'on
a voulu rendre accessible et on a
surtout voulu que ça plaise aussi aux
gens qui n'aiment pas forcément regarder
quelqu'un jouer aux jeux vidéo pendant
des heures même si moi j'adore ça et en
plus de cette web tv qui commencent tous
les jours à midi et qui finit dans la
nuit et qui recommence le lendemain à
midi comme j'ai dit qu'il finit par s'y
portable vous pourrez retrouver toute
l'équipe sur leurs onglets perso par
exemple une fois que j'ai fini mon
émission de 12h à 14h le lundi
si j'ai encore envie de stream et bien
vous pouvez me retrouver sur mon ongle
et perso sur le site tous les onglets
sont reliés at which et des chiennes
twitch mais vous avez intérêt à passer
par le site le stim point fr pourquoi
pour des petites fonctionnalités cool
qu'on a mis au point avec mika law alias
le bâtard kimba tous les jeux vidéo
auxquels on joue depuis maintenant cinq
ans j'espère que ces petites
fonctionnalités supplémentaires vous
plairont en tout cas que moi vous avez
vraiment intérêt à passer par le stream
point fr et en plus c'est plus beau que
switch over you réfléchir ça a prévu 2
doit sortir pour un brouillard et là
vous avez peut-être déjà cliqué sur le
site et vous êtes très déçu parce qu'il
est un compte à rebours le site n'est
pas encore ouvert il ou mercredi à 17
heures une heure avant la toute première
émission du site
le praj quoi le stream donc le prime
donc le échec si ça vous plait pas aussi
qu'est ce que c'est que le prime c'est
une émission qui va durer entre 1h30 et
2h qu'il y aura chaque mercredi en début
de soirée
normalement les poèmes ce sera à 20h
mais le premier on a avancé à 18 heures
parce que mercredi 8 mars ya quoi y'a
psg barça à 20h45 pg verts ça ça fait
quoi ça fait que les petits abonnés qui
tu es mais quitta d'or d'un coûteux
tourner le dos comme ça et 10
vous avez raison c'est le sport c'est
qu'ils font bref le poème c'est quoi
c'est une émission dans laquelle sûrs à
toute l'équipe le stream n'est à ce jour
pas d'idée non ça arrive deux chiffres
dès qu'ils vont être nommés vont choisir
qui seront dans leur équipe et ensuite
ces deux équipes vont s'affronter à
travers diverses épreuves
bon il est temps de vous dire qu'elle
copains ont accepté de rejoindre le
projet et je les remercie de tout mon
coeur parce que ça va être absolument
génial max hild amical au gotha gaxa
régira yacco jordan cyprien sky arnhem
les en cure manami zoulou et trinity
[Musique]
établissements pour eux soyez présents
mercredi à 17 heures pour l'ouverture du
site et mercredis à 18h pour le tout
premier stream ii le stream point fr
vous a concocté vraiment des trucs
sympas j'espère que ça va vous plaire
soyez présents et ce dans n'hésitez pas
allez folon la chaîne switch heel le
stream et apollo xi le stream sur
twitter hier soir description j'espère
que tous les jours vous viendrez vite
fait sur le stream voir les programmes
du jour voir ce qui s'y fait et que ça
vous plaira portez vous bien tu as tout
le monde
restez point fr
[Musique]